i'm an infectious disease epidemiologist
at kent state university in ohio
i mostly work on what are called
zoonotic diseases
so those are diseases that are
transmitted between animals
and people and earlier this week i wrote
a column for quantum magazine about
how our existing knowledge of
coronaviruses can
potentially help us inform um knowing
and understanding what's going on with
the covid19 pandemic
and so i'm here today on the quantum
magazine
youtube channel to answer some
additional questions that have come
in on social media in the comments of
that article
and um and elsewhere and there is a
function where you can also ask
questions during the talk and those will
be relayed to me
so i guess i'll answer as many of those
as possible
and i will get started with a few that
already came in
from various locations already so one
question
uh does immunity conferred from
infection
by a cold coronavirus so there are four
other types of coronaviruses that cause
kind of the common cold
in humans that have been identified
previously
so does immunity to these provide um
prophylaxis or i guess immunity to
covid19
and is anyone asking asymptomatic or
immune cases about recent cold
infections
um and the answer is i mean we're not
100
sure but probably not there doesn't seem
to be a lot of
um of cross-protective immunity between
the various
coronavirus species and even
when immunity develops it seems to wane
relatively
quickly so that's um looking at both
patients who had had sars kind of the
original stars from 2002 and 2003
and following those over time at least
the antibody response
seemed to drop off pretty dramatically
over
a period of about one to three years um
looking at some of the other human
coronaviruses the common cold
chronoviruses
that immunity also seems to wane
relatively quickly so
um so you would have to have had a cold
relatively recently which is one of the
things that they asked are people asking
if they've had colds and i don't know
any studies that are
doing that currently but you would have
to do more than just ask about colds
what you would really want to do
is to set up a study to sample
people over time and not only ask about
colds because those can be caused
only about the common cold
about 20 of those are caused by
coronaviruses so the other
80 or so are other types of viruses that
would not be protective
um so what you want to do is really
sample over time
and look at people who are getting those
common cold viruses
and then look at if they are able to be
infected with
sars chronovirus 2. a problem with doing
that right now of course is that
our testing supplies are very limited um
even even things like you know ppe
personal protective equipment for people
who are doing the sampling the swabs
that we use to do the sampling
are also in short supply so that type of
study
would be difficult to do right now to
get any kind of definitive answers but
i guarantee people are probably looking
at those types of things in other animal
models
um and other aspects as well so that is
definitely something that's on people's
minds
and one thing i wanted to add with that
was um that's also kind of one
hypothesis that's been put forward
regarding why kids may not be as
seriously infected with this
um man i have have symptoms that are as
serious
as adults get is that you know kids
are germy and may have
more colds from coronaviruses more
recently than adults have
so that's another thing that's being
investigated um
although i don't know you know i know
it's been
been bounced around the research
community so i know it's on people's
minds
um all right some other ones let's see
um all right uh in the realm of
neurological changes
and the search for characteristic
symptoms um which might be easier to
detect
to detect than loss of taste and smell
has anyone thought to look for changes
in hearing
maybe loss of upper octaves um
and i don't know about that uh that's
really interesting but
i don't know that that would necessarily
be easier to detect
um because you do have to have equipment
to do that and it also helps to have
like a before and after to know if
if before coronavirus infection people
were able to detect those
upper octaves anyway because of course
that's something that
many adults lose over time just from
being around loud noises and going to
concerts and things like that
um i have not seen any evidence that the
virus
affects um nerves of the auditory system
um with the olfactory system we do know
that
this virus and other coronavirus as well
can
enter through olfactory nerves and
can affect some of the tissue around
those and and may
cause kind of pathology in in that
manner and that may be what
causes um loss of sense and tastes but
we're not even sure of that yet
um so i think there's a whole lot of
open questions around
those neurological issues um with
with chrono with stars chronovirus too
that are still really big unknowns and i
haven't seen anything regarding
um hearing for that
all right um twitter so
um i have a question if the coronavirus
family has a low rate of mutations
why has it been so difficult to make a
vaccine um and this is from becca o
uh the motifs and structures in them are
relatively conserved and why are they
not
um very immunogenic and so for
for vaccines there are a whole lot of
things that really
need to come together to create a
an effective and safe vaccine and so
one of them is the mutation rate
obviously if something mutates really
quickly like influenza
it makes it more difficult to create a
vaccine because
um it mutates around that and so you
have to update it frequently
but that's not the only issue so you
have to find you know good antigens
ones that will will generate
a robust immune response and ones that
will not you know harm the host
so that's been you know the challenge
with this
and so we do have a good target antigen
in
the spike protein so this is the one
that is used to
by the virus to attach to host cells
and so there was a lot of work on this
in in canada sars
era so when that virus was recognized
and its kind of pathogenic properties
were realized and
and we saw how harmful this could be
there was a big infusion
in funding for vaccines for um
for stars chronovirus and so there are a
lot of groups working on it and a lot of
them had some candidate vaccines that
ended up getting tested
um some in animal models but then
you know stars went away and we were
able to contain it
and with with the other serious human
coronavirus merge coronavirus
it really hasn't um created the kinds of
epidemics
that's that stars did so there was just
kind of that a loss
of interest in coronavirus vaccines
for you know maybe like 2008
till basically the present um so a lot
of
of things got developed and then never
followed up on so that's one big problem
is is that they just never got
into you know robust human tests for
safety and efficacy we were just never
able to do those with the previous
candidates so they're there um but one
of the other problems potentially was
that when they used the whole
protein so the entire protein they did
find
that in some cases it seemed to cause
more harm to some of the vaccinated
animals than protection
and so this was through a mechanism
called antibody dependent enhancement
we see this with some other viral
diseases most notably dengue virus
where if you're infected once and then
infected again with a different strain
of dengue
you're actually more likely to have um
severe outcomes to get dengue
hemorrhagic fever
than um than those who had only been
infected once
so those antibodies don't necessarily
protect you they can actually
enhance the ability of the virus to
potentially enter host cells and
and um a number of other things that
lead to a more severe
outcome the second time you're infected
so they saw that with some of these
candidate vaccines and so
um instead of using the whole spike
protein they have kind of
chalked it up to look at the
smallest piece that is both
you know effective as in in antigen
but doesn't cause this kind of antibody
dependent enhancement so
um that's what they're doing for most of
the candidate vaccines is is some
pieces are parts of the the spike
protein and i would will say that there
are about a hundred different
vaccine candidates that are in some form
of development right now so there's a
lot of them out there
um so it's really been just that we we
kind of lost a lot of that work
um in the last decade or so and now
we're trying to play catch-up
in you know period of three months or so
um so it's it's not that necessarily we
don't know that we
you know that's super difficult to make
or that we can't make one or that we
really failed in the past it's just that
we can have stopped in the past because
we didn't have much reason to
um to go on so i think there's a lot of
hope that we will be able to create a
vaccine for this but
we're it's just kind of overcoming some
of those challenges
where we left off previously and now you
have to pick up those research programs
almost from scratch
all right um
so let's see um so this is from youtube
um so can't social distancing only work
if we um keep that going until we get a
vaccine
i'm assuming we stopped social
distancing before a vaccine are we just
going to get a second wave
until we hit herd immunity and therefore
social distancing didn't actually do
anything
so that's one of the things that we're
uh
working out right now um
so what we've done so far there is
evidence that social distancing in the
united states
and elsewhere um has worked pretty well
that we have slowed down the spread of
this
it's estimated that across the united
states
the basic reproductive number right now
um averaging again everything um is is
right about at one
so that means that on average
each person who is infected spreads it
to one other person so this is better
than
what it was initially in the outbreak
which is estimated to be
around three and this is because
most people are are doing this this
social distancing most
areas have implemented that but
a couple things that means one it's
still spreading um even if the
reproductive
number is lower um it still is not
extinguished because
on average still each person is
spreading it to at least one other
person which means it will continue to
to spread even if it's slower than it
would have spread um
you know in march um and
um sorry my dogs are running outside and
struck me
um and and so so it means it is still
spreading and then of course some states
are reopening so georgia texas others
are loosening some of their restrictions
on some of these social gatherings and
opening up
um you know hair salons and tattoo
parlors and and
restaurants in some cases so you do have
that
potential for additional cases from that
right
so as as
um public health experts what we would
really like
is to move from the mitigation
standpoint which is basically where
we're just trying
to keep this at a level where it doesn't
overwhelm our hospital systems
um where you know we can keep people
alive if they are seriously ill where we
have enough medical professionals to
deal with this and enough hospital beds
and things like that which we've
pretty well pretty much done so far um
to going back to a containment strategy
and so for that
you need to be able to test people
right now there are very few areas that
can test people
with more mild infections
most of the tests are still done on
people with with more serious infections
and also on healthcare workers who need
to know if they are
um are positive for covid19
and um they would have to take time off
off work
and not be around patients so that's
where most of the tests are going right
now
what we really need is more tests so we
can test anyone who has symptoms
and uh isolate individuals who are
positive and then find out who they have
been exposed to
over the last you know five or seven
days
and put them into quarantine so that
you can basically stop the spread of
this virus by getting infected people
out of society for a brief time until
they're no longer infectious
and keeping those who have been exposed
from spreading the virus before they
become symptomatic
before they even realize they're
infected so that's what like south korea
has done basically that's been their
model
is this test trace isolate um
but right now we just we don't have the
ability to do that we don't have the
tests we don't have as i mentioned
before
personal protective equipment for people
who are doing the tests to keep them
safe while they're
taking samples um we don't have the
ability to turn this around rapidly
you know one of the things that we
really need is to be able to take a test
and get people their results really
quickly which we don't
have right now and then
having this kind of mass quarantine i
mean not of the whole population but of
individuals who have been exposed
also is is logistically difficult
um so that needs to have a really good
protocol in place
and we don't have any of that so um so
that's still what we're hoping for
um is that you know we no one wants to
stay in
in kind of a stay at home a lockdown
situation for the next
you know two years or whatever until
potentially we have an effective vaccine
but um you know what you're going to be
doing is is if you
relax those social distancing measures
then yes you're probably going to see
another
increase in cases and then you probably
have to restrict those measures again
and and
do this over and over which um i don't
think is is good for
you know for society for mental health
for any of this
so um so i'm hopeful that still at some
point we can
ramp up that that testing and do that
instead of being in just this kind of
full society
mitigation effects until hopefully we um
we do get a vaccine
at some point all right
so let's see for our next questions here
um
all right um
[Music]
so if we do get a vaccine a history
infection after a year is possible this
is from the quanta
comment section um then even the best
vaccine will have to be given every year
so that's a question from ted
uh and we don't know again it depends on
what ends up
um being the vaccine that kind of makes
it to the finish line first or
the one that ends up being most
effective um
and it with 100 candidates out there
it's really hard to say what that is
going to be right now
so most vaccines you know are based on
the model of immunity that
um that the host would have naturally
but there are ways to kind of tweak that
so
um so you can in some cases uh conjugate
additional proteins to the um the main
antigen
of the virus um and make the immune
response stronger
for example um we do this with some of
the bacterial
uh vaccines that makes that make them
last longer um
and make them a little bit more robust
so there may be potential for that
um there may be potential to put this
into kind of live vectors
um not the live virus it's not the life
coronavirus but
other viruses that can replicate in the
body
and kind of introduce the body to maybe
pieces and parts of that sprite protein
as i mentioned before that
um that may be more antigenic um so we
just don't really know it
may be something that would have to be
boosted every year
um we don't know at this point but it
may also be that
you know even if immunity does wane
after
a year or or who knows um it may be that
future infections are still more mild
than the original one
so um so even if you don't have kind of
complete you know protective
antibody titers it might be enough to
keep you from getting a serious
infection and then
that might be all we care about um you
know you might not have to get
revaccinated so
there are a ton of open questions about
that right now and honestly there's
more questions than answers so um so
yeah so
unfortunately i just have to say we just
really um don't
know right now all right uh
let's see
um um
from youtube live um from molly given uh
how likely is it that we will discover a
really powerful drug that cures
covenanting quickly before a vaccine
gets licensed for widespread use
um and that's a good question i just did
an article um
for another outlet looking at some of
the the drugs that are being used
and uh for most of those drugs not all
but most
um that are being examined for treatment
for covenant 19 a lot of them are
already in use
for other other infections or other
areas um so if we could find something
that
is effective and it has already been
licensed for
something else it's already known to be
you know relatively safe
and um has already gone through all the
approvals it's much easier to take those
and kind of repurpose them
for treatment for um copin 19 than it is
to develop something completely de novo
where you have to
you know determine its safety profile
and and everything else
so if we find one of those that are
already approved for other
infections or other conditions then yes
that i think
that those could be um in place before
we get to a vaccine
but from you know the tests we've seen
so far and of course there are many that
are ongoing so
so who knows what the outcome of those
will be too um
i haven't been particularly impressed
with the results that we've seen um so
far uh we saw the
the results from some of the um remember
trials the other day
and um the ones in china really didn't
go anywhere
the nih ones that were done here in the
united states seem to
maybe show some progress but that's also
an iv drug which makes it just a lot
more difficult
to get to a larger number of people
especially because it seems that one
really might be better
if used early but you know if you have a
person with
know mild symptoms um
are you going to give them an iv drug
and how is that going to be used so
um so i think there are a lot of a lot
of issues that that need to be worked
out
and of course a lot of other drugs are
under investigation
so um so it kind of depends on if those
are already approved
and could just be kind of co-opted for
coping 19 or if they're completely new
and and need to go through those studies
which would take longer
all right um
let's see
um some of these i've kind of already
addressed so um one was also from the
um kwanzaa comments section asking about
um
from jessica fay harrison do you expect
that any of the current vaccines that in
development could interact
with stars kobe 2 in vivo to produce an
increase in in pathogenicity
by an antibody dependent enhancement
type of mechanism so
i discussed that a little bit um but
that's definitely one thing that they're
um
actively looking for and trying to avoid
so they know they've seen that in
previous stars
vaccines and animal models um so right
now we have some
vaccines that are already in um in
testing phase in humans
and so phase one trials are for for
safety so that's the first thing that
they're doing
um so we have one already from the nih
which is
a mrna vaccine so they actually inject
the
rna rather than the protein itself and
then the body produces the protein
um so that's one that is again already
in these phase one safety trials so that
i guarantee that's one of the
the things that they will be looking for
in these volunteers
um is is those types of reactions
um once they um re-challenge with the
vaccine
so um i don't know i know they're the
vaccine developers are very cognizant of
that
so um so
i don't think any of the final ones
would
end up with that type of reaction just
because they're looking for that so
carefully but
you know once once you have this in a
large group of people even if that's
something that's a one in a million
reaction
you're really not going to know um if
that happens until you have
a large number of people using it so
that is something that i guarantee will
be
tracked very closely for any of these
vaccines once any kind of get into
into production potentially um
and then to kind of go along with that
from os on the live
youtube chat here how long will it take
to create a vaccine and then why does it
take so long
uh so uh we we don't know how long it
will take
you know the the time that has been
usually cited is 12 to 18 months i think
that's optimistic
uh most vaccines take
more on the the um
timeline of at least a decade and some
many more um
so i work in my laboratory with a
bacterium called staphylococcus aureus
and you know some of you may have had it
it causes
skin infections but it can also cause
really serious disease including
bacteremia pneumonia and death
and we don't have a vaccine for that we
have tried
since at least the 1950s maybe before
looking for different candidates
different antigens
that would be appropriate for a vaccine
and we don't have one yet
now it's a bacterium and not a virus so
there are some differences but
even for some viral diseases for hiv we
don't have a vaccine for
rsv respiratory syncytial virus that
causes
serious infections in infants especially
um pre-term infants
we don't have a vaccine and one of the
reasons for that is also
one of the the tested vaccines caused
antibody dependent enhancements
similar to what they've seen in some of
the animal models for bursar's vaccines
so um so so just creating a vaccine
is really a little bit of an art and and
a lot of luck
um in addition to the science so
i'm hoping you know i'm i'm i'm
optimistic
um i hope that we could have one in that
12 to 18 month timeline but
um i'm also a realist and and i'm not
counting on it so i'm certainly not
um you know putting anything in to to
bet that we will have one on that
timeline
and you know of course we want to make
sure these are these are safe
most importantly so right now as i
mentioned there are
um at least the one vaccine and i think
one other that are in these phase one
trials so you look at safety first
and then you do another trial with
slightly large larger group of people
where you look at safety and you can
start to look at
if they actually work you know it are
people producing an antibody response
um and then usually with phase three you
start to introduce it to
a large group of people and then you see
if it actually protects them against
disease
and um so you need a large group of
people to do that
in um and then you need to see if it
actually protects them from getting
you know infected with with sarge
chronovirus too
to kind of ramp that up and make that a
little bit quicker
uh some people are suggesting human
challenge studies for that third part so
that you would actually
you know vaccinate people with with the
candidate vaccine
and then um expose them
purposely to sarge chronovirus 2 to see
if it protects them or not
um so that's being proposed there are a
lot of issues with that a lot of
um people who support it a lot of people
who who don't who
um who are concerned about the ethics of
that especially when we don't have a
treatment
and when it seems to do some weird
things even in people that are
would be good challenge subjects like
those who are young and healthy and have
no real risk factors
so it always is dependent on
how some of these trials go um if
everything works great in the first you
know
first phases
18 months i think is is possible but
then that remember that is
till we get a functional vaccine
and that's only kind of the start of it
in some ways then you have to
make enough doses of that to give to the
population
and it may be something where you need
multiple doses
to have a really effective immune
response so each individual may need two
or three doses to be completely
protected okay well just the united
states alone there you're talking you
know
almost a billion doses um if everybody
would need three
so you have to have uh you know
factories and and things that can
manufacture that um
and those those don't just spring up
overnight so
so you either have to start working on
that now or you have to co-opt
that from facilities that are already
making vaccines
and then do you have end up with a
shortage of other critical vaccines
because you've
devoted that time and
that area to making vaccines for
coronavirus
so again there's a lot of logistical
challenges even after you have
a vaccine that may be scientifically
tenable
then you still have to get it produced
you still have to get that out to the
population which is going to take
you know if you say 18 months for
an approved vaccine i mean at least
another probably six months
or more depending on on what type of
vaccine is
it is and if we have the facilities that
can do it
um to really get that ramped up and kind
of
out to the population um to protect them
so
yes long answer for for um maybes uh
18 months to two years i think to be
optimistic
all right there's other ones um
uh from brian and the quanta comment
section um what are the medium term
prospects of a general solution to viral
infections so
so short term obviously is just kind of
social distancing what we're doing now
um which again i don't think is a
tenable long-term solution long-term
solution would be something like a
vaccine
so medium-term um i think would be you
know if we can get something to treat it
some of those drugs that work
but one of the other interesting things
that again is is
still in a gray area still being
investigated
but some people are looking at the
potential of
other live vaccines um
as a way to kind of almost
i hate to say boost the immune system
because that's really not scientific but
um a way to provide kind of broad
general protective um
innate immunity we think against a
variety of pathogens
so um you may have have seen some of the
studies looking at or some of the
really suggestions um not a lot of
studies so far
but the suggestions that um the bcg
vaccine
so a vaccine against tuberculosis that
is not not used
routinely in the united states but is
used in some other countries
that individuals who are vaccinated with
that
may have some resistance
to being infected with um sarge
chronovirus
ii um there's also kind of similar ideas
about that with um with the mmr
vaccine so measles mumps rubella
looking mostly at the rubella part of
that is as
maybe something that is maybe generating
some protection there
um so
whether those will actually pan out i
don't i don't know because there's a lot
of confounding issues in there
um for the bcg vaccine that's
primarily used again not only but
primarily used in developing countries
who may not have
um testing for coronavirus that is
really
adequate so maybe we're just missing
some cases um maybe there are other
factors that are that are going into
this
rather than just just the bcg vaccine
for mmr one of the reasons they're
looking at that is again
with this aspect of of children having
you know much more mild symptoms are
being completely asymptomatic
and wondering if that's because uh that
they have
um higher levels of immunity to
to mmr because they've been exposed to
that more recently than most of us
adults
so those are really just kind of
hypothesis generating right now but
people are looking into those and i
think there was an article out to maybe
today
in the new york times on some of that
work and some of the rationale behind
that
so if we could find that some of those
work that would be fantastic so then we
could just
um you know give those to two
populations and
um you know even if they don't work
specifically against coronavirus if they
could be protective
um you know at least to help the
population kind of
reduce um reduce transmission of
chronovirus or reduce the severity of
symptoms
those could potentially help in that
kind of gap that we have
between now and development of a
specific chronovirus vaccine
so keep your eye on those it may
completely fade out and maybe
maybe junk there may be nothing to um to
back it up but
those are some areas where people are at
least looking right now
um all right let's see here
um all right so it's always about i'm
skipping over your question
i'm sorry it's probably because i just
maybe don't know enough or um
maybe it's more for a kind of clinician
um
or something than myself um like there's
one sorry from
from leonardo do anticoagulants work to
treat the respiratory symptoms
and i have no idea that's a great
question i don't i don't know it i'm
sorry
sorry leonardo um
from dean morrison um a lot of health
care workers are dying
from covid statistically speaking could
this be because of higher original
exposure
um and maybe so that's one of the things
i talked about in
um in the article um for
some other corner viruses where they've
tested them again mostly in animal
models
um they have seen that a higher initial
dose
of exposure does seem to lead to more
serious
infections and so with healthcare
workers especially again if they're not
being supplied with adequate ppe
um they and they're working with
patients that are sick you know more of
them that may be expelling
higher levels of virus that may be doing
procedures where the virus becomes
aerosolized
um so it's easier to to to breathe in
um that's one of the hypotheses for the
reasons why some of these healthcare
workers are coming down with
not only illness but in some cases
really severe illness even though
they're otherwise seem to be kind of
young and healthy
is that exposure to a higher
load of virus and especially a higher
load of aerosolized virus
um they also did see this with sars
especially in the early days before
um again before it was recognized and
and before measures were taken to
to really use like n95 respirators and
things like that to protect health care
workers
that there did seem to be kind of a dose
exposure there that um
more virus you were exposed to more
severe symptoms you you could get
and we have a little bit of evidence of
that um from the early days in china
also again
when healthcare workers were exposed to
this before understanding what it was
um that's um using
um again and n95 respirators and face
masks and and things like that to
protect health care workers
um did seem to decrease their mortality
as and and
incidents of serious infection from that
as well so
we think maybe um again you know that's
something that will be
better resolved with good animal models
and animal experiments
where you can directly challenge them
with different doses of of the virus and
look at the severity of their outcomes
so um so that's something that i'm sure
will be coming from some of these
um animal studies um and on
that line um uh jcg856
asked how good do you think the animal
models being used are and again that's
when i just
a little too far out of my area um i do
know some of the biologists who are
working on this
but um i'm not sure what their thoughts
are on the animal models there are a lot
of different ones being used
too i mean from um you know your typical
kind of
um rodents to to other things so um
so i don't know if we know yet and i
should mention that
that's one of the issues with studying
this is that
um at least in the united states and i'm
pretty sure this is
common around the world though not
completely um
100 dealt with the same way um
but using live stars chronovirus 2
in a lab in the united states you have
to have that in a bsl3 laboratory
so um so there are different levels of
biosafety
that um that are required for different
pathogens so something like ebola is a
bsl4
pathogen so this one is a bsl3 which
um there are not really that many bsl3
laboratories in the united states
my laboratory is a bsl2 so i could work
with
um coronavirus you know just rna but not
actual infectious
virus i couldn't do you know any growing
up of the virus in my lab or
any animal studies anywhere on our
campus because we don't have a bsl3
laboratory
so those are kind of rare and trying to
do
all of the studies that everyone once
done with this coronavirus
um is difficult and challenging because
um
it's hard to work in in those
environments you get tired
um you have to wear all of the the gear
and the
respirators and things like that so it
makes working with these viruses
rather difficult and so while we all
want some of these answers
like now like yesterday um it just is
difficult because
because of the limited number of bsl3
labs and also because of the limited
number
of people with real expertise in
coronaviruses
because as i mentioned earlier you know
funding has waxed and waned for these
and so to have a real bonafide
coronavirus researcher who
has done this for years there's only
you know a handful of those maybe so um
so we we are having a lot of people who
have expertise
in other viruses now moving into
coronaviruses but there's still that
dearth of lab space so it's making it
really difficult
to get at some of these answers maybe as
as soon as we would like
um all right um from the concept comment
section
um from rad if if both stars one
coronavirus
sarge chronovirus one and coronavirus
two enter cells via ace2 receptors
um which i talked about in a previous
quanta
article that you can search on the
website why is it that only covid19
impacts the upper respiratory tract um
and so the answer for that is again we
don't 100 percent know
and so that's when i think that would be
really great to be looked at some of
those animal models
um but it it's it for one it's it's
i should say that it's a spectrum so
you can have some of the other
chronovirus one in the upper respiratory
tract
um it's it's not like it's all or
nothing
but um stars ii does seem to be
much more prominent in the upper
respiratory tract and stars corner virus
one in the lower respiratory tract so
that's
one of the reasons why we think um stars
ii is more transmissible person to
person because of all that upper
respiratory tract replication
whereas sars original was more deadly
because of that lower respiratory tract
infection
but less transmissible but the exact
reasons
aren't 100 clear um
and just because they use the same
receptor doesn't mean they bind to it
with the same affinity so that seems to
be one thing is that
um oh no and i'm probably going to mess
this up um
uh i want to say sars chronovirus 2
binds to it more strongly
um i would have to double check that i'm
sorry um
but but um so there can be differences
in binding affinities and also it's not
just the binding
of of the virus the receptor that's kind
of
like step one but there are other things
that happen as well
um so there are different proteases
infusion proteins and things like that
that
um also lead to um you know really
allowing this virus to
um to replicate inside the cell so there
can be differences in those as well that
affect um kind of locations of
of tissue tropism and things like that
that
for that i don't think we know all of
those answers right now
and exactly why those are different they
both also seem to again
at least be able to bind to cells in the
gi tract but
aren't necessarily a gi infection even
though they can cause some
gastrointestinal symptoms so that's also
you know we don't 100 understand all of
that either
so um so those are some of the things
again that once i think we have some of
those good established animal models
and virologists to work on them and lab
space to do that in
that we'll start to see some of the
answers to some of those questions come
out
because i think they're still kind of
unresolved even though i think a lot of
people have different ideas
about what that might might be
um let's see
um all right so um so from the youtube
live chat um so bats host a lot of
chronoviruses is there something we can
learn from the way bats immune systems
handle the virus and that is kind of a
million dollar question too that's
something that's
um you know a lot of people have wanted
to know because
because bats harbor not only you know
coronaviruses
but our hosts to um
viruses like ebola and marburg nippa and
hendra um
you know all kind of rabies um you know
a lot of different pathogens come from
bats and part of that is because
i mean bats just are incredibly diverse
um they're
um you know we have so many different
species of bats
that it's not surprising that we get a
lot of spillovers because they just
harbor
their own different um
viral groups and then those eventually
can
cause infections in humans so why don't
they seem
to cause harm to bats and what are we we
don't really know
um so there's a paper out i mean maybe
um a decade or 15 years ago
that tried to review the literature on
bat immune systems and at that point
there was almost nothing that was out
there
i mean bats are really hard to work with
in the laboratory they don't really
survive well in captivity
um so it makes it difficult to do a lot
of experimental work on them so
sometimes what we have to do is
more observational data or um
you know things like that so um so it's
difficult to really
know precisely why why all of that is
different
um there's also been some suggestion
that
just because of the way bats you know
live
that they they fly they have to have a
high metabolism so that they can
you know expend that energy on on flight
that may also play a role in their
immune system if basically they're
um you know fevered all the time
essentially they have a high body
temperature then maybe that is just kind
of keeping
the viruses that they have in check um
so that they don't
you know stick in the the bats
themselves but
those are all really more hypotheses
than anything because again they're just
really difficult
to test because we don't have a lot of
of
um good experimental data on some of the
bats so
a good question that i unfortunately
am not able to provide a great answer
for
um all right um from paul gildan
how um definitive of coven 19 are the
chills and shakes if these symptoms
occur
only sporadically over a few days and
yeah i wish i could tell you we don't
know
um i mean that's one of the things with
all the symptoms is that
one we're seeing kind of an expanding
case definition of what are included as
far as covid19 symptoms we just saw the
cdc added some
additional ones the other day um and
even so
some of those are still pretty
nonspecific i mean cold and chills
it could be potentially covered 19 it
could be
influenza that's still circulating
depending on where you are it could be
you know a number of other respiratory
viruses so
so we don't know and that's one of the
problems with again lacking really good
testing especially some kind of a rapid
test
or a point of care diagnostic like you
do for flu and you can
you know get your results in 20 minutes
um so
without those yeah we really can't say
definitively because those are so
non-specific and and you know could be
anything from from flu to food poisoning
um so yeah we just uh don't know yet
um from inking um in kits um
how long will it take to develop herd
immunity
um and that's another good question that
we don't know so
when you look at the um percent of the
population
that will need to be infected by any
kind of virus to develop herd immunity
that is based on how transmissible they
are in a population
so with this one again assuming an r
naught of three
okay um you would have to have
basically about sixty percent sixty to
seventy percent of the population
immune in order to reach that herd
immunity threshold
okay now remember herd immunity is not
like a switch it's not all or nothing
the you know the higher number of people
that you have in the population that are
immune
um the more difficult it makes for that
virus to
find a susceptible host and to spread so
you know
any immunity in the population is better
than none um even if it's not kind of at
that herd immunity threshold yet
but for this again because we have so
many open questions about immunity we
just don't know
so um so if we would
go over the course of say you know 12
months all right
and 40 of the population would have been
infected
with stars coronavirus 2 um
in theory 40 of the population then
would be immune
but what if that immunity wanes after a
year so you have the people who were
infected at the very beginning
have maybe you know are maybe no longer
functionally
immune so you're not really at 40 of the
population anymore
you're at a lower level than that so
those are some of the questions that we
um we just don't have answers to and we
won't have answers we just can't have
answers
without following people over time so
it's only something that we will know
after
you know one year or three years how
long that immunity
lasts and if people are really protected
from reinfection or not
because we usually use you know
antibodies as kind of a measure of that
but
it's not a perfect correlation um it's
just one of the usually the easiest
things to
to measure and kind of most
straightforward things so
so we don't know and that's what
concerns myself and
and some other epidemiologists about um
like sweden that is using basically herd
immunity
and um protection of the kind of elderly
and other vulnerable
populations um as theirs
their strategy you know that just let
this come in
let's get a good population that has
immunity to it
and that's how we'll deal with it but we
don't know if that'll work
um so we'll be looking at at you know
countries who are taking that strategy
we will be looking at people who have
been known to be infected
and once we have good ants body tests we
can kind of follow them
um over time to see if that immunity
wanes and if so how quickly
or not so um so the herd immune immunity
aspect is something that also
you know we know in theory but whether
that will actually happen
in practice it will be completely due to
like the behavior of this
um virus and how it interacts with our
own
immune system
all right
[Music]
let's see um
[Music]
all right from rachel graham uh do you
believe this can be a chronic infection
um we also don't know that
um i think it's unlikely
um most of the human coronaviruses as
far as we know do not
cause a chronic infection um the common
cold ones or
you know stars or mers we haven't seen
that at all um
in the animal chronoviruses there is a
feline one that can cause a chronic
infection
but that seems to kind of be an outlier
and i talked about that a little bit in
the article
um so
i i think it's unlikely but you know
with biology with viruses
until you have some evidence i would not
say
completely rule that out um
anything is potential but um but i i
think that is not
something that is is going to be likely
with this
virus
oh let's see um
sorry it's hard to answer and go on um
read these these questions as well
um
so um can you explain in simple terms
why covet 19 wasn't created in the lab
um maybe i can uh
i mean first i think it's it's unlikely
that
that happened i know there are some
really big advocates of that
but i think what some people don't don't
realize is how often these spillovers
from
animals to people happen okay so there's
even a term for it
um in in the field um referred to it as
viral chatter
so these spillovers from
animal populations to human populations
of
different types of viruses and so we
know this happens
a lot and and most of these spillovers
are not
documented so it often takes something
that is pretty dramatic like
right now like this coronavirus pandemic
or like an ebola outbreak um so
you know something where you have really
clear symptoms
you have a population where you can see
this
going through the people there
and something that comes to the
attention of public health authorities
so a lot of these
spillovers are often dead ends and
they're they're either they don't
um spread from human to human so they
may go from animal to person but then
not from person to person
so they die out um or they can circulate
maybe undetected for a long time this is
what happened with hiv
hiv actually is not a single spillover
event it didn't happen just once it
happened multiple times with related
viruses
that's why they're slightly different
they came from slightly different
animals
um from you know chimpanzees to [ __ ]
manga bees to gorillas
that independently went from
those animal reservoirs into the human
population and then
spread from there but again we didn't
detect them initially because they don't
cause
like you know symptoms as
um obvious maybe as ebola
and they happened in populations that
were you know not being carefully
monitored
you know in many cases it was before um
we had a lot of
the science to be able to detect them so
you know that's why hiv and aids
wasn't found until the 1980s in the
united states when it hit populations
that you could see okay something weird
is is happening here
in in these populations but some of the
earliest
um viruses crossed over into human
populations you know almost a century
before that
um and had been spreading undetected so
um that's a long introduction into
saying that i think it's
it's just based on how everything works
it is much more likely that this is a
natural spillover than
um something created in a lab looking at
its genome sequence it doesn't have any
markers
of being um you know altered by
humans um i know and after that was kind
of
um pointed out the other idea came that
well okay but it was in the lab
and then it had just gotten loose from
there which
is tougher to rule out but um if so it
was not a virus that ever was recorded
as being in that laboratory was never
identified or sequenced
um so and and you know we
i can't say lab accidents never happen
but they're certainly much less common
than just those natural spillovers from
wildlife reservoirs or other animal
reservoirs into humans
so um you know i i think it's
it's tough to prove a negative but i
think it's it's much more likely that it
was a natural event
than some kind of a laboratory um
accident right so maybe we'll do one
the final one here uh
let's see
um lester is the idea that viruses
evolve to become
less less pathogenic a rule of thumb
um and that is one thing that that
certainly people have
put forward um about this virus in
particular about viruses in
in general and it's not i mean it's it's
um
people see that uh we have identified
multiple
or you know multiple mutations um in
coronavirus lineages and i think people
hear a mutation and associate that with
with meaning as far as um
changing pathogenicity either making it
worse or making it
um you know less serious that's not
necessarily the case you can have
mutations that just do nothing that's
most of the mutations right
um and there's this idea that if
something
you know jumps from again maybe a
non-human
reservoir into people um that over time
if it co-evolves
with humans that it will become
you know mild or asymptomatic um and
that can happen sometimes but it's not
something that necessarily happens again
we had ebola in west africa
um that went through many many many
chains of transmission
um from 2013 to 2016 before we were
finally able to
extinguish that outbreak um and there
was really no
evidence over that period of time that
it was becoming less pathogenic
mortality rates decreased in some cases
but that seems to be more related to
getting good care just getting good
supportive care and not to any actual
properties of the virus itself
so um so with with viruses and with with
you know evolution like that there's
really no hard and fast rules
um there's always lots of
maybe general outcomes but even that
doesn't always you know there are always
exceptions that prove the rules right
so um so i don't think we should assume
that this is going to become
less pathogenic or anything or evolve in
some certain trajectory we just
i think really don't know right now and
it will depend on on
a ton of different factors including
whether it's it's you know maybe
recombines with other corona viruses
or whether it sticks to itself or um if
it just
hits on any particular mutations that um
would make it more fit and whether those
mutations would make it
more or less pathogenic again i don't
think we can
can necessarily foresee that right now
all right so with that
um let's see here um i think i will um
kind of stop this right now and thank
you all for for joining me for tuning
in um for those of you who may have come
into this
midway or or um if you missed this on
the first round
um this will be on quanta's youtube
channel at some point so um so keep an
eye for that
um you can also subscribe to their
youtube channel um and if you're
you want to learn more about other
developments in epidemiology and biology
and math and physics and all the other
things that
um that quanta covers um then please
check out quantum magazine.org
and um subscribe to the youtube channel
where they have a lot of other
uh q and a's with other scientists as
well right
so thank you for joining and stay safe
out there take care of each other
have a good afternoon thank you
yep
you